حقيقه محاوله اختطاف الرضيع السوريه
المولوده تحت الانقاض وتيك توك تدرس رفع
الشعار ادفع لتشاهد وماسك يفاجئ العالم
بهويه رئيس تويتر الجديد اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
عشره ايام مرت على زلزال سوريا وتركيا الى
للاسف يعني خلف اكثر من 41 الف قتيل ومئات
الالاف من الجرحى ومئات الالاف من الناس
اللي نزحت من تحت الركام لمكان على الاقل
يكون في يعني اسقف تحميهم حجم الدمار كبير
وصادم وخسائر بالمليارات واكثر من 50% من
المباني اللي ما انهارت في منطقه الزلزال
في تركيا مهدده بالسقوط فيعني تخيلوا حجم
الدمار والكارثه وبالنسبه لعمليات الانقاذ
فلا زالت مستمره وما انتهت على الرغم من
مرور اكثر من 200 ساعه من وقوع الزلزال
وامس تم انقاذ عدد من الاشخاص على قيد
الحياه
لينضافوا الى قائمه معجزات الانقاذ في
زلزال تركيا والسوريه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]
عمليات الانقاذ مستمره والامل بالحياه
ووجود ناس احياء مستمر وتجسد في امراه تم
اخراجها بعد 222 ساعه في قهرمان وقهرمان
مرعش تركيا
[موسيقى]
سيده تركيا الثانيه عمرها 77 سنه سجلت
معجزه باخراجها من تحت الانقاض بعد 212
[موسيقى]
في زوجين اتراك كمان تم انقاذهم في كوجالي
وهذولي وثقت الكاميرات قبل ما يطلعوا
محادثه بينهم وبين فريق الاوقات
النهارده
[موسيقى]
والله تمام
يعني حقيقه لحظات الانقاذ هذه صراحه لا
يمكن ان ننساها وخاصه لحظات انقاذ الاطفال
اللي انحفرت في عقولنا وقلوبنا ومن بينهم
الطفله اللي انولدت تحت الانقاض في ريف
حلب بمنطقه جنديرس السوريه اقيل انه
المنقذين والدتها متوفيه وهي عايشه والحبل
السري لسه موصول الرضيعه فقدت كل اهلها
وصورها ومقاطعها من المستشفى وصلت كل
انحاء العالم والكل صار بيتابع اخبارها
لحظه بلحظه ويبغى يتطمن على صحتها ووضعها
خاصه وانه ما نجا من عائلتها اي احد
اطلاقا الاهتمام بالرضاعه مل الدنيا
وبدانا نشوف حتى عروض لتبنيها من مشاهير
وحتى الناس من داخل سوريا قالوا انه في
عروض لتبنيها من غير مشاهيره من كل
الجنسيات وطلعت كمان اخبار امس بتقول انه
النجمه انجلينا جولي المعروفه بحبها
للتبني عرضت تتبنى الطفله لكن الفريق
المعالج للر ضيعه نفي الموضوع وقال انه ما
له اساس من الصحه
الساعات الماضيه سمعنا خبر تاني عنها بس
هذا الخبر كان مفجع فشفنا تقارير عن
محاوله الاختطافها من داخل مستشفى جيهان
اللي بتتلقى فيه الرعايه وقيل انه مجموعه
دخلوا المستشفى وسالوا عن مكان الرضيعه
وحاولوا يتوجهوا هناك لكن العاملين في
المستشفى منعوهم فاعتدوا عليهم المجهولين
وضربوهم وتركوهم مصابين كمان لكن تمكنوا
من حمايه البنت وما قدروا انه يوصلوا لهم
البنت بالمناسبه من اول لحظه في طبيب في
المستشفى تولى رعايتها وسمعنا انه سماها
ايه وحتى خلى زوجته ترضعها ومتكفل
برعايتها تماما لكن شفنا اخبار تانيه كمان
بتقول انه في اقارب لاسرتها من بعيد ظهروا
وقرروا يسموها عفراء على اسم والده الله
يرحمها
من بعد ما صار الزلزال والناس تعاطفت مع
كل المنكوبين بسبب حجم الكارثه الكبير
بدات المساعدات وجمع التبرعات من جمعيات
ومنظمات وشفنا حتى مبادرات فرديه ودوليه
للمساعده لكن في اشخاص من ضعاف النفوس
قرروا انهم يستغلوا الزلزال وبداوا
يحتالوا لجمع تبرعات بيقولوا انهم راح
يساعدوا فيها سوريا وتركيا ولكنها بتكون
ايش وهميه وبس بيسرقوا فيها الناس وعبر
وسائل متعدده كلها رقميا الاول عن طريق
حسابات على تيك توك بتنشر فيديوهات الصور
وبتطلع بث مباشر لساعات بتحط في البث هذا
صور الدمار والضحايا وحتى بيجيبوا صور
مؤثره مو من الزلزال اصلا يعني وبيرفقوا
معها عبارات يستعطفوا فيها الناس مثل من
اجل سوريا ومن اجل تركيا وغيرها الكثير
واللي بيسال طيب كيف بيتبرعوا عبر تيك توك
تيك توك تحديدا في ميزه اسمها هدايه رقميه
وهي هي هذه الناس بتهديها بعض خلال البث
المباشر وبتتحول هذه الهدايا الرقميه
الفلوس فبيطلعوا المحتالين في لايفات
وبيطلبوا هدايا من الناس على انه راح
يحولوها لفلوس ويتبرعوا فيها وكان طلع
كمان متحدث باسم تيك توك وقال انهم
بيعملوا على
منعتيال وتضليل ابناء المجتمع الراغبين في
المساعده الحقيقيه يعني اما الطريقه
الثانيه فهي عبر حسابات على تويتر بتنشر
تغريدات صور مؤثره مع روابط للتبرع عبر
حسابات او محافظ باي بال رقميه والمختصين
اللي بيحذروا من هذا الاحتيال باكدوا
للناس انه بيبل اصلا من 2016 مو شغال في
تركيا اصلا فما تنخدعوا باي احد يدعي انه
حسابات هذه بتركيا والضحايا الزلزال في
ناس كمان مكتفه وبتغريدات بس بل انشئوا
حسابات كامله مزيفه للاغاثه على تويتر مثل
اللي شايفينه امامكم عشان تبين او تظهر
كانها منظمات شرعيه او منافذ اخباريه
وبيجمعوا التبرعات فيها وبيحولوا الفلوس
لحسابات بيبا الخاصه فيهم وعلى فكره تويتر
اغلق احد الحسابات هذه وشغال كمان على
اغلاق حسابات اخرى اصلا
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد في تقارير شاغله عالم
التكنولوجيا ومستخدميها كمان وبتتكلم عن
انه تيك توك بيدرس فرض رسوم على محتوى
معين يعني خلي مثلا صانع المحتوى عنده
محتوى عام لكل المستخدمين وعنده مقاطع
ثانيه هذه يقدر يشوفها بس اللي دافع
وطريقه الدفع بحسب التقارير بتدرس تيك توك
كيف تعملها ممكن يعملوا رسم شهري يبدا من
دولار واحد ويشوف المستخدم كل المحتوى
الحصري هذا او يعمله رسوم تدفع على كل
مقطع حصري بشكل منفصل طيب ليه تيك توك
بيعمل كده
تيك توك تطبيق تواصل دخل عالم التطبيقات
الكبرى ونافسها حتى اللي سبقوه في السوق
من سنين وفجاه تفوق باعداد المستخدمين على
فيسبوك وتويتر وانستجرام تيك توك السنه
الماضيه حرفيا كان على القمه لانه ببساطه
حتى غطى على جوجل وعدت فتره كان فيها اكثر
موقع بتم زيارته يعني متخيلين موقع او
تطبيق زيارته اكثر من جوجل يعني هذا الشيء
مهول طبعا من الاشياء اللي ساعدت تيك توك
جدا جائحه كورونا وحبست الناس والان
المنصه اللي ناجحه كثير لسه ناجحه بس
بتعاني لانه مع رجعه الحياه لطبيعتها
الناس بعدت عن التطبيق شويه اعداد
المستخدمين اليوميين او المستخدمين
اليوميين قلت والمستخدمين الجدد كمان قال
له ومن هنا طلعت تيك توك بفكره الدفع هذه
وهي للامانه مو فكره جديده في عالم منصات
التواصل يعني يوتيوب عنده خدمه بفلوس
مقابل ميزات معينه وتويتر برضه في ميزات
مقابل فلوس بس يمكن الغريب في موضوع التيك
توك انه هيدفعوا الناس مو مقابل خدمات لكن
بس علشان يشوفوا محتوى خاص وبعدين فرضا
مثلا هذا الشخص دفع وراح نشر الفيديو من
عنده ببلاش وقتها ايش حي تيك توك ايش
حيكونوا استفادوا واصلا تيك توك كيف راح
تزيد اعداد المستخدمين اذا فرضت رسوم
التقارير على فكره كمان بتتكلم انه تيك
توك راح توسع برنامجها اللي بتدفع من
خلاله لصناعه المحتوى عشان يبقوا على
المنصه احنا حبينا نعرف مشاهدينا لو انتم
كمستخدمين مستعدين تدفعوا مقابل محتوى على
التيك توك وسالناكم عبر حساباتنا
واجاباتكم جاءت كالتعليم 95% قالوا لا و5%
فقط مستعدين يدفعوا
الخبير التقني بصنع المحتوى عبد الله
الغفيس اهلا فيك معنا عبد الله انت من اي
فئه من ضمن ال 95 اللي قالوا لا ما راح
ندفع ولا الخمسه في الميه اللي لا يدفعوا
ممكن عشان يشوفوا كليب او فيديو حصري
لا انا بروح مع الخيار الاول ما راح ادفع
صراحه نعم طيب يعني اذا قدي كذا الناس
عندها رفض لموضوع الدفع وطريقه كمان يعني
تيك توك بتقول انه على فيديوهات محدده ليش
ممكن تيك توك برايك تعمل خطوه من هذا
النوع
صحيح هي طبعا الفكره انه فائده للطرفين
فائده اللي هو الصانع المحتوى وفائده الى
يعني نفس الشركه
فصنع المحتوى ممكن يبتكرون طرق معينه ممكن
اني اضع هذا الفيديو يعني ما يظهر الا اذا
دفعتهم ممكن انكم كانه مشاهده مثلا مبكره
مثل الافلام او غيرها من الاعلانات
نشاهدها الان ثم بعد فتره بتتحول الى
مجاني في امور كثيره ممكن انه نعرفها لما
يتم اطلاق الخدمه بشكل رسمي يعني انت
بتقول انه هذه او هذا الشيء حتعملوا تيك
توك بالتعاون غالبا مع صناع المحتوى
فالفكره كمان انه يفيدوا او يزيدوا
الفائده لصناع المحتوى عشان ينتجوا اكثر
يعني
صحيح هو هذا الهدف انه زياده اكثر او دخل
اكثر او صناع المحتوى ممكن حتى انه نشوف
ناس مثلا تستخدمه بالتحديات او البثوث
اللي موجوده الان نروح مثلا افتح المقطع
الموجود علشان تشوف الفكره ما ادري يعني
اكيد انه بنشوف افكار يعني كثيره وقتها
صحيح طيب تعتقد كمان موضوع انه الدفع على
كل فيديو الحال يعني منطقي ولا لازم
الموضوع يصير اشتراك شهري يعني تجربه
يوتيوب وتجربه تويتر اشتراكات شهريه حتى
لما بنتكلم عن المنصات كبيره مثلا يعني
شاهد نتفليكس عندهم اشتراكات حصريه برضو
بتدفع زياده وبتاخد اشياء حصريه بس موضوع
فيديو هذا مو غريب
هو ممكن يكون انه غريب يعني في منصه ثانيه
لكن اعتقد المستخدمين الخاصين مثلا احنا
شايفين انه يشترون الهدايا الرقميه
ويدفعون فاعتقد ان الطريقه بتكون قريبه
منها مثلا الموضوع مو غريب يعني على
يوتيوب شفنا على تويتر وبعض الحسابات اللي
ما تنشر اخبار الا عند الاشتراك او ما
تنشر محتوى الا من خلال الاشتراك فاعتقد
ممكن انه يصير بنفس الفكره وممكن بعد فتره
يعني انها تحسن فتكتوك الان قاعده اتحسن
يعني كل فتره شفنا قبل فتره لما اعلنوا عن
موضوع التجاره الالكترونيه وكيف انهم
دمجوها داخل التطبيق والان هذه الفكره
فكلها امور حابين انهم يزودوا الايرادات
كذلك ينمون عدد المستخدمين بس انا مثلا
لما يعني ادخل والمفروض انه انا افتح حساب
وكمان ادفع فلوس صراحه ما راح اشترك في
المنصه يعني في نهايه اليوم يعني خلاص
الواحد اشتكى من كثره التطبيقات والاشياء
اللي جالس بيدفعها يعني فهم كيف فكرتهم
انهم حيزيدوا التطبيق خاصه انه احنا شفنا
الناس بتقول ما عندهم استعداد يدفعوا
هي بالاخير بتكون موضوع اختياري وهذه هنا
بنرجع الى شطاره مثلا صناع المحتوى او
كذلك شطاره التطبيق كيف انه بيخليه اكبر
بس ممكن تيجي رده فعل عكسيه صح صحيح ممكن
وحتى انا شفت اليوم يعني التعليقات ناس
كثير بتويتر كان اللي يقول بحذف التطبيق
وما ادري ايش ما راح استخدمه ففعلا ممكن
انهم يفقدون عدد اكبر
هنا وقت قعدت تصير ازمه ويصير في تراجع
ونشوف الموضوع طيب نحن بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كان معنا الخبير التقني وصانع
المحتوى عبد الله شكرا لك عبد الله
[موسيقى]
امس قال الماسك شارك عن بعد في القمه
العالميه للحكومات في دبي واتكلم عن
التكنولوجيا والتعليم والعمل واكيد كان
لازم طبعا يتكلم عن منصه تويتر اللي من
وقت ما صار مالكها ورئيسها وهو قالبها
راسا على عقب قرارات وجدل واستطلاعات رايي
واقالات واستقالات افلام يعني ففي الاول
ماسك اتكلم عن اهميه تويتر واهميه انه
الناس والمسؤولين يعبروا وينشروا تغريدات
وينقلوا رسالتهم اللي حابين يوصلوها للناس
عن طريق المنصه وانه يكتبوا هذه الرسائل
بنفسهم مو عن طريق مثلا شخص او فريق او ما
الى ذلك واتكلم كمان عن المنافسه مع
المنصات الثانيه وكمان عن تعرضوا الدائم
للانتقادات وكونوا دائما في موقع هجوم من
الناس عليه ماسك في القمه نسال كمان متى
راح يعين رئيس جديد لتويتر كونه هو بنفسه
ديسمبر قال انه بيراس تويتر مؤقتا وراح
يستقيل بيبحث عن شخص مجنون بما في الكفايه
ليستلم عنه الوظيفه واصلا هذا الاعلان كان
اعلنه من بعد من بعد ما عمل استفتاء قبلها
بايام ووعد بالالتزام بنتيجته وسال الناس
هل اتنحى عن رئاسه تويتر وقتها اكثر من 17
مليون شخص صوتوا في هذا الاستفتاء
والنتيجه كانت 57% ونص صوت وقالوا نعم
بالعوده لقمه الحكومات مصر ان سال عن
وعوده بالتنحي عن الرئاسه ومتنوعين رئيس
جديد وهذا كان رده
كويس
[موسيقى]
بعد هذا التصريح فاجانا ماسك على تويتر
بانه يبدو انه خلاص لقي اللي مجنون كفايه
عشان يكون سيد تويتر الجديد وكشف عن هويته
في سلسله تغريدات الرئيس الجديد هو كلبه
لطيف فنشر ايلون ماسك تغريدا عليها كذا
فيها صوره لكلبو وهو جالس وراء المكتب في
تويتر ولابس تيشيرت مكتوب عليها سي اي او
وامامه اوراق وعنوان التغريده الرئيس
التنفيذي الجديد لتويتر رائع وكمل بتغريده
الثانيه قال فيها الرئيس الجديد هذا افضل
بكثير من هذاك الثاني هذه التويتر عاد
ملغومه وصار في جدل في فهمها يعني ما حد
فهمها كويس هل هو يقصد انه فلوج الكلب
افضل منه هو شخصيا ولا افضل من الرئيس
التنفيذي السابق براج اجروال اللي طلعوا
ما وقف مديح في فلوكي لا لا مكمل ونشر سيل
من التغريدات عن مميزات الرئيس الجديد
فقال انه ره في كل ما يتعلق بالارقام
والحسابات وفي تغريده ثانيه قال انه كمان
عنده ستايل نار ومن بعدها بدا الاخذ والرد
ففي حساب كتب لمسك يبدو انك ما لقيت مجنون
كفايه يرقص تويتر غيره ورد
مثالي للوظيفه وفي حساب ثاني صخر من
تغريدات ماسك بتخيل لاعضاء مجلس اداره
وزاره الجديد فحط صوره ماسك وابن ماسك
الاصغر اللي هو اسمه هذا اكس اللي كان كده
اسمه معادله
واختصروها باكس ويبدو ان النكته عجبت مره
ماسك لانه رد عليها بايموجي واعمل لها
كمان ريتويت
[موسيقى]
خبر اللي راح اقوله يمكن يكون غريب من
نوعه بس في نفس الوقت يمكن يعجب كثير
صراحه من اللي بيعانوا خصوصا من عدم
القبول خلال مقابلات العمل بسبب مثلا
المظهر او بيعانوا من التوتر من انه تكون
الشركه طالبه مواصفات معينه في الشكل مو
متوفره فيهم او كذا يعني ففي شركه صينيه
حلت الموضوع وطلبت من المتقدمين لوظائف
فيها انهم يجوا لابسين اقنعه مثل مو
شايفين قدامكم والسبب انه هذه الشركه تريد
ان تحقق العداله وما تختار على اساس
المظهر ابدا يعني نقدر نسمي الموضوع قناع
العداله الوظيفيه ومو بس المرشح بيلبس
القناع لا كمان اللي بيعمل معه مقابله
العمل بس ما اعرف السبب يعني بصراحه ليش
بس انه قالت الشركه انها كمان بتقدر قدرات
الفرد اكثر من المظهر وانه لبس القناع
بيقلل من اجهاد المقابلات للمرشحين يعني
للشركه تبغى تمسح عباره حسن او حسنه
المظهر اللي بنشوفه شروط طلبات التوظيف
وحقيقه انقسمت ردود الافعال على اليسار
فمنهم اعتبر هذه الخطوه المناسبه للناس
اللي عندها توتر وقال لك من مقابلات العمل
وفي ناس لا شافت يعني عمل دعائي للشركه
والناس بتحاول انها يعني كده تثير وسائل
الاعلام كذا بتجذب اهتمامهم والكلام هذا
كله وعلى فكره مو بس لبس القناع اللي كان
لافت خلال المقابله لا في شيء ثاني الشركه
كانت حاطه موظف جلس بيوزع قصب السكر على
المرشحين
ليش يعني ما اعرف ما اعرف لسه الموسم
طلعها يعني
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم
دائما بامكانكم متابعه مقاطعنا على كل
صفحاتنا على مواقع التواصل انا اعود
والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه جديده من
تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]